our friends karen and noah venaclawson
have taken our show on the road
cruising across the country shining a
light on these amazing people and places
along the way
and they recently made a pit stop in
albuquerque new mexico
where they rattled up some new friends
take a look at this special edition
of barrymore tours
[Music]
hey drew we're in albuquerque new mexico
at the american international
rattlesnake museum
and home of the world's largest
collection
of rattlesnake species we're gonna
slither on in and take a look
so we're here with bob myers the founder
and director of the american
international rattlesnake museum
bob it's great to meet you thanks for
hosting us good to meet you so tell us
about the museum when was it founded the
rattlesnake museum was founded in 1990
31 years ago
so this is a huge tourist hot spot
obviously
oh we get in excess of 50 000 people
every year how many rattlesnakes are
there here well we have
34 different species and subspecies of
rattlesnakes
we have an albino here named drew
of all things should we go take a look
all right let's do it thanks this is
drew the western diamondback rattlesnake
she happens to be a blonde she is albino
hi drew
is she dangerous she's dangerous because
of her eventual size
the length of those fangs the quantity
of venom that she carries
what's the biggest thing people get
wrong about rattlesnakes
probably top on the list is the old
wives tale that you can tell
the age of a rattlesnake by counting the
segments on the rattle
the truth is they get a rattle segment
every time they shed their skin
let me introduce you to aj
aj adam jr he is an eastern diamondback
rattlesnake
the largest species of rattlesnake
in the world found in the southeastern
part of the country
how long is this one aj is six feet two
inches now oh my gosh
that's almost as tall as you are he's
beautiful absolutely beautiful thank you
for letting us see him
absolutely i love that there's a snake
called drew
i really do like that i know that i'm
always seeming like so
happy and optimistic but i have a
stinger we all
do nobody likes to be messed with and
that's the funny thing
is when you're always so optimistic
people think you don't have like
a spine in the dark side